how's it going citizens of the reject
Nation it is John it is Roxy Strayer and
we are back for another first time watch
and today it is Christmas in May we're
watching violent night Roxy how are you
feeling as a Jew
I'm feeling like my juke card's about to
get taken no you want to know what until
somebody comes along and helps produce
my Hanukkah movie all we have holiday
movie-wise are Christmas movies so I
can't deny it I'm not a liar Christmas
movies slap there's so many different
genres of them and I tend to like so
many of them that it's like this little
Jew girl she's got it she's gotta watch
that's right you you're included in our
secular Christmas bubble just for this
occasion thank you so much absolutely
I'm glad to have you here this will be a
multiculture it's like when the Rugrats
taught us about Hanukkah this will be
the reverse of that but guys go ahead
leave a like on this video comment below
with your Christmas movie favorite and
uh Hey subscribe to the channel as well
hit that notification Bell be sure to
check out Roxy as well as the world
girls on social media whirling and
twirling out there and hey if you want
to get the full experience alongside us
get everything that gets cut out of
these reactions highlights come join us
over on patreon.com the real rejects
where you can sync up with your own copy
of violent night and without further Ado
I think we are ready
to celebrate uh the return of our Lord
and savior let's do this he was a Jew
true that boy
[Music]
I wish we had a cup of cheer I know we
just have cups of Despair here
oh another one oh so vertical so I'd
like to change that
receive man is this like it's like bad
santa great so far you just get off
of taking a break between shifts I guess
you could start you ain't driving are
you I steer a little but the Rangers
in case you were wondering
this is my fourth year as a Santa I
forget why I started doing it in the
first place the money
hauling a vocation
maybe this is my last year oh it was
Christmas
no I'm kind of down with it very good
how do you know my grandson's name I
that dough leads to the roof put it
together you know deep in your heart not
if Santa's not real though like in this
world
told you he was real yeah but in this
world do the are there presents coming
to kids like that otherwise yeah they
must be
he's flying around with his gift bag oh
come on man it's good luck when a bird
poops on your head so that has to be
great luck yeah that's true
oh
no no no no no
Merry Christmas Judy
Merry Christmas Daddy you're filthy
animal
thank you for doing this I mean not
together I'm not doing it for you must
not be Daddy messed up that's a bummer
because that's a beautiful looking
family across the board don't worry
they'll reconcile somehow Christmas they
have to yeah I bet you're excited for
Christmas what did you
for not to work on Christmas Eve must
have been naughty this year because here
I am oh
oh I'll never get over the fact that you
grew up like this yeah I think this is
the year that mom's gonna kick herself
upstairs and choose one of us to start
running the show and I gotta tell you
Jason that I'm gunning for your ass
I'm sorry about my sister my sister's
pride and joy oh this is the
blue
[Music]
kiss me in front of my son
listen you it's Christmas so why don't
you take your best offer gift wrap it
and RAM it up your box
please you are King suck up you named
your kid Gertrude oh wait you named your
son bertrude
and how I wish my favorite granddaughter
everyone
that makes her sound like oh oh she
doesn't even know the meaning of the
word woof and Mom I think Gertrude is a
beautiful name I only call her Gertrude
Merry Christmas it kind of reminds me of
ready or not but I didn't put it
Christmas I'm loving this movie oh oh
boy milk after a bunch of beers not the
way
oh Amazon
which is the best luck to get peed on or
barfed on by Santa as he flies by well
we haven't seen him poop on anybody yet
but that would be number one yeah that's
true number two would be number one this
year has been weird I never got to say
no
at Christmas she wants her parents to
get back together yep 10 bucks yep you
go put your PJs on and I will beat two
minutes
what you got a suit lined up what do you
want for Christmas either a new guitar
or a bicycle oh my God what about you
you're low-key greedy
just want joy and peace for the world if
you could have one gift early really
what is it what is it what is it what is
it what is it what is it
that is a very special walkie-talkie
that's Magic
okay
Tara must oh my God
that's cute what you got right there is
a direct hotline of Santa Claus himself
hello
oh he's not I really only want one
person for Christmas I want Mommy and
Daddy to make up yeah you did it I want
that too
which one of you did that you can't go
two seconds without crapping on the roof
like a bunch of pigeons
you puked from the sky
where is Rudolph where is he
oh is this Trudy's house I think so
Steve's head
[Music]
that's the good [__] Santa I told you he
has milk Santa has hella milk yeah
next time I'll bake for us when we do a
reaction hell yeah every time themed
awesome pre-warship right there
all right in the milk glass
oh I wish these chairs did that
[Music]
does this help oh hey you fixed my back
a little just then
Christmas is all right are you Americans
don't celebrate my favorite holiday oh
no boxing day oh no
whoa I knew it's not coming imagine
being hit so hard you are ko'd like
I know right
how hard was that hit or how weak was
your head is that a real elf
elves would never stoop to this level
Roxy they are pure moral beings
Santa's different
oh Grandma your Wi-Fi sucks when he was
small I begged you to beat him
at least they didn't I don't know what
would have made this kid turn out all
right let's go
my grandparents love him John Leguizamo
yeah I do too my car broke down a little
ways out here where the hell am I anyway
GT light Stone family compound I'll call
you a toe
foreign
[Music]
what kind of movie is this violent night
don't worry that's the only violence in
the movie it's never good when the first
person they kill is the black guy though
it's just like come on what if things
really change this time we got out from
under my mother's thumb tonight
[Music]
uh they're just killing people Polar
Express over here
I think there's a Mrs Claus or is that
he's so upset because there isn't I
don't know let's I'll probably come up
at some point we know Rudolph saywall
please don't kill them
forget your Christmas code name but
you're a badass where are you going
she's going for the Panic Room what yes
without us yeah what go bertrude go why
wouldn't she have told them to come to
the Panic Room because she doesn't care
about them at all leeches
can Santa get killed or is he magical I
mean some degree of magical so I don't
know is he or is it just like the
reindeer they're magical and he magic
out of the fireplace so yeah that's true
to protect us we protect the primary
asset wow
who the hell are you you can call me Mr
Scrooge
get him
why don't they just shoot him I don't
that's a good question
[Music]
it's a good POV on there hey step aside
tinsel peppermint sweep upstairs I
have light Stones together this is
putting Santa really behind schedule I
know all those presents my presence your
bicycle back by the surf and stairs
oh boy
oh come on no no no no no
oh
you got me downstairs now I'm just gonna
take my back
I'm just gonna scooch up that chimney
he's definitely on the naughty list now
yeah
whoa no no no no
Jesus they left him yeah let me get shot
at you know
oh that's a nice detail
what are you gonna go to the roof for
there's nobody up there anymore yeah I
guess just to get out of the room maybe
he can summon them somehow
this must have been fun to choreograph
yeah totally I'm really into this oh
ice pick
oh yep yep yep oh no oh no nope nope
oh yeah
wow
now you're on the naughty list Santa he
didn't do that um it's not his fault
where's Rudolph when we need him I bet
Rudolph would show up at the end I do
too some kind of glowing red light
[Music]
I told you oh
come
on shot in the head I told you that too
singing this version next Christmas any
idea who you're
of course
woohoo
shut the [__] up
Santa's moral debate with himself right
now framed perfectly through this
frosted window sober up Santa
I feel like this movie is going to
unexpectedly make me cry I know all
about your extraction team I also know
that they're on their way
how long it's going to take them to get
here even though the credit ratings and
their sizes oh excellent you have 300
million in U.S dollars sitting in your
personal Vault downstairs
woof disappeared in the fog of War
except it didn't really disappear did it
Gertie
because you stole it did you know about
this and this family
uh yeah you knew
you'll never get involved oh oh because
when you you hit the panic button it
reset the combination
I keep telling you
I know
I love John Leguizamo man yeah maybe
Phil
he repelled down buildings with him
you're gonna tell me just fill out a
window all right look Lively gang we
gotta gopher
got a reindeer
I'm just gonna talk to Santa oh
[__]
[Music]
it's bigger on the inside oh
oh
whoa
I don't want to kill you
big fat guy Gray beard
I'm gonna rip yours off
[Laughter]
oh God
[Music]
[__] whoa
darts let's go
whoa nice
[Applause]
Santa's resilient AF man
wow oh gosh
oh my God oh my God yep violent night
is this it man 4 or what no oh Jesus
oh
yeah nice
crispy
hello
yes
[Laughter]
oh what kind of animals
oh my God
are you gonna help us those are the
people I'm gonna get you out of there
I'm gonna take a lump of coal
shove it
straight up the ass
yes
careful though you're still nice come on
sweetie we want to keep on the nice list
you know
can I say butthole then
it's borderline how about being this
technically yes uh anus is the text
amazing
well he looks Jolly as well who the hell
is he it's crazy that David Harbor
hasn't shot with any of them yet I know
and then I want to find my reindeer and
I want to continue delivering my
presence
[Music]
oh [__] with me no
my holiday to-do list to find you and to
end you and to wipe my ass with you in
this whole [__] holiday oh my God
Santa Claus is Coming to Town
stripping leading
oh no
his hand
it's a lot of blood looked like it came
from under his coat who's playing Santa
Christmas party
no it's okay no no no
no
did that take his finger off or mangled
it at least come on it's not called a
finger cracker oh Christ I better be
looking at flat like in three seconds
I'll do it
this you will
be stop hurting my daddy
Santa will get mad
Santa's my friend
and beat you up
come on telling the truth though you
aren't talking to Santa yes I
know you're not come on now yes
oh
tough moment God damn it Dad Sam is just
a thing adults tell kids to make him
feel better okay
your mommy and I give you the presents
and we say that from sound but then this
sand has actually been giving gifts yeah
what about the unaccounted for gift that
shows up into your tree do you know how
hard it is to be a little Jewish kid
growing up and no Sam is not real
and not spoil that for all you guys
you're a good friend it was like don't
tell anyone probably the first secret I
ever kept
wow
what is what happened you got stabbed
yeah it's always gonna burn it yeah I
got cauterized that wound okay you gotta
clean it first bro
Santa's headed
it's like what is that that animated
movie that Guillermo del Toro produced
Rise of the Guardians or whatever
has like the tatted up like Eastern
European Sonic is David Harbor tatted
these have to be for the character
the wrapping paper this is amazing yes
what's a guy gotta do to get some
Neosporin
okay
oh
throwback yeah
hi hey
I was just wrapping something up
let's just tell the kids that Santa's
real to make them feel better yeah a lot
of parents say that
but I still bring presents to kids that
need me
oh
and Trudy lightstone wrote to me she
said that she felt lonely sometimes and
so I brought beautiful little stuffed
rabbit Mr Bunny no you said you had this
amazing dream and that
afterwards all you wanted
but what do her parents think that that
came from yeah too busy to notice
touching man this is touching it's so
sweet
Trudy is so lovely who hurt you
I'm just a lonely kid shut up
it's your Christmas magic to make them
love each other again
his claws and I've been going on you're
uh
1100.
[Music]
wonder if they still bone
okay so in the business oh geez they
call this
a pitch deck it's called explosive force
starring me
and if you look in the back oh my God
God gift have a golden opportunity oh my
God this is so awkward
the sentimental photo of the day I was
born
I remember
I was there
[Music]
kind of a thoughtful gift
I think I left it in the car no I saw
you put one under the tree earlier
you don't use this one right damn you
bertrude it's my favorite whiskey
you can skip the note
he was expecting to be gone by then
laying it all out
thank you Jason
respect's a little a little honesty
nickelman
nickamund I was a warrior a Raider Thief
me and skull crusher
oh Crushers Maya
my hammer huh
great question
because I was mean
naughty list Mr Bunny he wasn't just a
toy
friend
and you mean more than just the presents
you bring
that's why I believe in you Santa
is like a Tinkerbell moment how does
every scene between them is just going
to make me cry I don't know why
she's just the purest I think that's
really sweet of you all right fellas
look alive look alive
y'all know the plan time to move up
time to lube up okay
let's get us a snowmobile Chase come on
Merry Christmas
[Laughter]
like a video game who knew that did that
your guitar hey I was a good boy what's
the gimmick with the bag it's a magic
hand in out comes a present I really
understand
you don't think I know you're an idiot
but don't be an idiot Out Loud come on
he's just Insanity claws with a tricked
back
oh dude no
come on everybody knows that Christmas
dreams are [__] nah
it will come back right magic somehow my
father used to make a big deal out of it
he got laid off in that Christmas
couldn't even afford a tree no Christmas
dinner no gifts and it was all they had
it all see all that you'll tight cheer
through their window mocking me
foreign
was that the Gramps got up to take a
piss and the two was scared the [__] out
of each other and uh
fell down the stairs and broke his neck
and he died hurt people hurt people man
Christmas ruined my life
okay but you know what it set me on the
path and made me the great man that I am
today I'm sorry Jimmy
oh
Yorn
against that Huffy bike you want it back
in 82
one you wrote me 50 times about
are they use soap suds oh it's the
Snowshoe found in the attic I know I'm
just saying what's it made of probably
[Music]
whoa nice
doesn't look as graceful coming back out
you can't fit up there it's impossible
well you see one weird thing and then
you think you're in a fairy tale
flavor God this is reindeer yes
you know what's happening here Bjorn
oh hey
[Music]
oh
my god oh Jesus dude Morgan's Gonna Save
Us
oh God Jean-Claude Van [__] just
ditched us sweetie
Jean-Claude Van ditched us
yeah but
she said [__] ditched us I know I'm
making it more Compact and kitchen your
line was better yeah it's my second
draft a bunch of ex-military guys I
think they're ready for you they better
be
we're on a tight schedule
oh yeah
damn
where are they working with them or why
do they kill him yeah I know link was
almost said it's their extraction crew
yeah we got I'll go for running around
complicated [__] and causing problems or
some intuitive dresses Santa but I'm
telling you I'm telling there's
something weird about them might be the
real Santa
he's on the roof
I got eyes on them oh God waste no time
[Music]
use one of the other chimblies bro where
are your reindeer
they're just circling the earth now
as a kid I love unwrapping Christmas
presents so much that my mom would wrap
empty boxes for me
I didn't care that nothing was inside
[Laughter]
[Music]
as you do now the sun stole it
probably and the sun's her son stole it
was gonna take the kid and the wife and
that's what he wrote in the card yeah
and she has that you think I'm right
It's gotta have something to do with him
maybe he's gonna redistribute the money
where we're supposed to or to some
charitable but he said to the wife like
what if we didn't have to do this
if you could have anything in this world
what would it be
hmm
oh
I could see Mrs Claus again then you
make that wish come true oh
[Laughter]
my hammer they're naughty
spanking I'm alone for coal give them
their lumps give them their lumps and
shove it straight at their anuses yeah
yeah
they're right outside
let's go let's go
it's got the man bun and everything
what's up
these guys
like a plate full of cookies
Santa's gonna what he's gonna eat
through these guys like a plate full of
cookies
oh he's in the chimney
oh
nice oh geez
whoa where's the money
all right Scarface it upsets me in a way
that makes me want to just randomly
shoot at people uh what what uh what if
you randomly shoot the only person who
knows where it is
yeah good point
[Laughter]
solid point
[Music]
oh yeah oh damn
you suck that candy cane oh
what a shot
damn dude
I'm just gonna say what we're all
thinking Santa is hot he is hot let's go
Santa hottest Santa easily
I need some feedback guys
nice what the hell is going on
you know
oh
let's go I want to see skating Santa
though
sure
I want to see a whole ice skating Santa
musical number
oh wow not bad that was great
oh
Jesus Christ
wrong guy just Jolly Old Saint Nick yeah
oh yeah oh no oh stocking stuffer
I got a lot oh cool guys do look at
explosions
go ahead so how'd you find out that we
were coming I didn't I was stealing it
yeah coincidence
you get one per movie
spent years groveling to you in the
meanwhile
I was destroying the only good thing in
my life no
look at this little idiot
she's home alone in them
yeah I can't be the only trap you know
booby traps don't work unless you hide
them yeah
music is a little [__] quite forward
yeah
oh
[Music]
wow
wowie no
ice cream
I hated that
good job babe good job honey let's go
Trudy
Wowie
[Music]
oh geez you have tetanus bro all the
tetanus
oh no it's gonna put him in the eye no
no no no no
oh oh good just no no no back of the oh
it's in the third eye
this is great great Home Alone moments
oh
yep classic
now wire oh nice
oh no she kicks up
oh
interesting
oh ow
yes good
that's all you got
whoa
It's a gun for a kid
yes let's go Santa
Father Christmas finally they're on set
together I know I hope let's see that
wide yeah get that hug
just turn around yeah
you're about to murder an innocent child
naughty don't grab that gun
it's part of the lightstone Legacy we're
horrible people
[Music]
a light Stone takes what's theirs I'm
proud of you son of course the three
wise men presented him with gifts of
Frankincense
mer
and cash
you gotta kill Atlanta first
I say shoot him first what no no no
don't shoot him you gold digging [__]
okay I changed my mind shoot the
alcoholic [__] first
why don't you die with some dignity
hey damn Bert
pick up the gun and shoot him yeah a
little bit
although this seems to be working
well it's nice to do something as a
family for a change
oh yep
yeah that did the trick
okay Mommy
this is my friend
Santa
anybody know how to work these gizmos I
think so I used to hunt with my dad
oh my God
no damn
just don't shoot him
[Music]
oh who brendom
perfect snowball oh
oh my God
hook up
come on now it's gonna break up last
second I know it
[Music]
yes the word of the Lord toboggan
oh
some nice boots they're like we don't
want to pay this actor for a speaking
role whoa
[Music]
you see the perfect murder is done with
a icicle
no weapon no evidence
that lens flare
someone's standing off side of the
camera shining a flashlight now be
better for Trudy
obviously a trap
oh
whoa dude whoa
how are you gonna fall for that
where's Mrs Claus
where's Rudolph
oh
killed his best friend hates Christmas
that's almost as bad as kills your best
friend when I kill you
this whole God holiday finally ends
whatever it takes
oh Christmas dies tonight Christmas dies
tonight evil dies tonight
whoa dude
[Music]
oh
of course I'm worried about the bag of
toys yeah where did all that magic go
oh no
oh
[Music]
no oh my God do not drag Santa like that
oh
[Music]
Cheap Trick pocket snow
what are those shoes
yeah he's got like this special deep
snowshoes ice kicks
woof
oh
where's the little girl come save him
the last Christmas
I gave you my heart he ripped his hand
out
[Music]
whoa whoa
[Laughter]
that was gnarly that might be one of the
craziest deaths in film history the
you [__] yes this ends now
damn right it does
well done grams but Santa
I know we need to keep him warm
all the fires are going out we need to
find something to burn
I got an idea what burn these bodies
why do they need to keep them warm I
mean
if they want to Hope and try and save
them
oh they're gonna burn the money yeah
that feels like extreme
[Laughter]
rich people do things like that this
brave brave man whoever he was
you have to believe
oh you'll bring her back
this is Tinkerbell you just have to
believe everybody believes I believe in
him too yeah come on
I believe it in two
so do I let's get this over with
I guess I do too I believe too
can't just say it though you gotta feel
it
they're feeling it
oh my God Christmas magic
you still don't really understand
how it works
well you show up
huh
yes I'm talking to you
you got my sack
my spirit you went home and you got my
spare sack
bear sack dude get the bag
oh
oh Mrs C
D
hello beautiful
yep it's a Christmas miracle
thank you
for believing in me it's reminding me
the Christmas still matters
that I still
matter we believe in you Santa
keep yourself
she gave him his ho ho back that's right
man oh oh
on Cupid on Donner and Blitzen where's
Rudolph he's on assignment Someplace
Special
well done cute
well done Tommy vercola
Josh Miller That's the name of my cousin
I know a guy named Josh Miller a little
bit who I believed worked who co-wrote
the Sonic scripts and I wonder if it's
the same guy not my cousin that you know
of
nope
[Music]
Locker living the dream see this guy
dead as hell Santa is real all right
don't end up on the naughty list
do better now do better
great great mid-credit scene ah that was
funny
yeah
this is much of a meme of as that
character is that was pretty funny
well done
what did you think Roxy what did you
would you like it really cute uh nice
fresh take while referencing the
classics like obviously home alone and
feels very bad santa asked at times but
that was like
really really well done did a good job
there yeah I agree it's it's funny you
know because on the outside too when
they first announced this I had a split
reaction to the very concept because
part of me was like all right cool semi
uh not like horror but you know like a
bloody violent Santa movie part of my
brain goes cool and then the other part
of my brain goes ah like we've done edgy
Santa so much and like bad Santa is fine
to me but I don't have like a big love
for that movie particularly not a belly
Bob guy I like Billy Bob but just I
don't know that that movie would you
wear his blood or no I would in fact I
would love just all the blood-filled
Billy Bob crystals I could get would you
rather wear Billy Bob's blood or David
Harbor's blood David Harbor any day of
the week I'll take it David Harbor slaps
he does and and that's the thing is is
this uh was a lovely and pleasant
surprise because it did have a lot of
heart and while it had a lot of action
and edginess and stuff I thought they
managed to not just rest on that like
they actually at least thought
everything through a little bit and and
yeah like he's just so he works so well
as both a Charming warm you know
avuncular fatherly kind of you know
Santa presence but he can also really
sell the like oh this guy used to be
like a viking warlord you know yeah so
this might be the dumbest
non-christmas celebrator question I've
ever asked but is there any Merit does
is there a Santa backstory I'm unaware
of there are many I mean lore sure I
mean I I don't know like the fullest
extent of like the Saint Nicholas story
but but yeah I mean these things come
from like old traditions and stuff and
this one like
I mean this is compiled from much of
like the the secular like I don't know
if Saint Nicholas uh was some kind of
warrior necessarily but
my my guess is probably not that I doubt
there would be such a blood soak but you
never know and I mean like Saints or
sainted for all sorts of reasons like he
had a Saint Nick and Thor had a baby and
then Milner came with Santa yeah look up
the Saint Nicholas story
um but yeah I mean I don't I didn't get
the sense that this was trying to be
something no no I was just curious
because I don't know if there's any like
you know I've never seen this backstory
of Santa before I don't know where that
comes from
he was a a bishop of Greek descent uh
from the maritime city of Mira in Asia
Minor and because of his many miracles
uh that were attributed to his
intercession he is known as Nicholas the
wonder worker you know my favorite thing
that this movie did was
what Roxy thank you for asking what was
that what was your favorite thing this
movie does
like I don't want to tell you until you
are curious about I'm very curious now
what is it I was curious anyway you
didn't give me a check you went straight
into you know what's curious what is
curious he didn't even give me a moment
of of of you know the spark wow what are
you gonna do next take all my money in
my Vault okay jokes on you I don't have
any money or a vault uh okay anymore
my favorite thing was that I had a few
questions throughout that I I said out
loud and some I thought in my head like
wouldn't they know if Santa was giving
presents or like how's this work
whatever and I like that they kind of
attempted to answer it like they knew
that people would be asking questions
and they were like we don't really fully
understand it's a Christmas spirit it's
just how it's the Christmas magic this
is how it works if you believe and then
you see it other people don't believe
then they don't see it we only go to the
people who believe like they they did
it's kind of like how when you watch
Back to the Future or any uh time travel
movies and you're like I want you to
explain your version of time travel
enough but not too much but I want you
to know that I needed a little bit of an
explanation and this movie was like
we're gonna explain Santa a little bit
not too much but like we know you've got
questions we're gonna sprinkle some
answers and they gave me just the right
amount of answers that I wasn't being
super jaded like all that you couldn't
do that you're like well that's
Christmas magic and how am I going to
argue with that's Christmas mad it's
like oh good that works for me yeah no
totally I thought because there is you
know the magic of Christmas and there is
a certain air of Wonder and and I think
to just go full in like part of me
expected a movie like this to have some
kind of like well Santa's got this Elite
government training or some [__] like
that and yeah I like that they give us
just enough to be like okay he was once
a warrior he present probably wasn't
always this guy maybe this is some kind
of mantle that like maybe there is some
the Santa Claus business that exists in
this universe but but yeah I like that
we meet this Santa as he is he's been
this guy for a very long time he doesn't
even fully kind of have
the the complete yeah knowledge himself
and I think that's kind of a nice
humanizing thing is yeah it's the magic
I don't even know quite how it works
because then it gives me the idea that
yeah maybe he became the Santa we know
him as you know through some kind of
magical process or ritual or right and
he doesn't even really fully maybe
understand or know and he's like yeah I
had Parents yeah and it's like okay so
at some point there was not a Santa and
then about 11 000 years ago he met Mrs
Claus so he'd have to assume maybe
that's right around when he became Santa
must have been or something they could
definitely and I know this isn't the
point I know I always harp on this and
people get annoyed with me in life they
could definitely do a sequel to this or
a prequel to this or like something more
with David Harper's sandwiches yeah I
know that sounds so silly but like I
think that they could definitely do
another uh violent night too sure I mean
I like I like the
I'm torn because part of me I like the
Lord that they drew here partly because
they don't have to just explain every
corner of it but it does leave you like
a good amount of mystery and fun to play
with and I like the idea that you know
these various
I don't know uh Christmas tropes and
rituals can kind of factor in in
different ways or or there seems like
there would be a lot of fun potential to
use the iconography and the you know
traditions of Christmas in various other
you know applications in this kind of
universe was this a straight to
streaming movie I don't think so oh
really no is that a theatrical release
yeah I'm surprised by that only because
it was kind of like a bottle movie
we're pretty much in one location the
entire time and they used a lot of
[Music]
um
up and coming actors that don't have as
big of names yeah a lot of people that
you recognize certainly but not sure for
sure David Harbor is easily and and John
leguizama I mean they're the two yeah of
course and then also the vacation woman
uh Beverly yeah right Beverly yeah yeah
so I think that you're not a fanjulo
is that what they're called according to
Kimmy Schmidt or whatever that's from
yes oh I never I saw commission I don't
remember that oh yeah but even like I
don't know the husband and the wife I
know I've seen them but yeah I don't I I
was I was sitting there trying to figure
out like where do I recognize these
people from because I know I've seen
them before but yeah maybe
um but just like wow I'm I'm interested
to see how did this movie do in theaters
I know people loved it but did it make
its money and some I feel like it did I
mean it certainly seemed like it made a
splash when it came out and I feel like
it may be hung around the box office uh
like that on the poster says you better
watch out yeah dude it's got all the
Chris they thought everything with this
movie
um but yeah like I and two you know you
have it from the outside where you feel
like um I don't know you hear from the
producers of John Wick and you see the
the the you know at least having seen
like the trailer uh I got the sense that
this was going to be some kind of thing
where you have uh
I was trying to look at the box office
that's what I thought you were doing
Mojo I'm very very curious okay well you
got to fill the air while I talk
Christmas movies well I was trying but
then you ditched it because those movies
tend to do very very well
um and this is now we watch this on
Amazon right yeah I wonder how it did
back on the replay too I had a friend
actually a friend of mine uh has often
said she's an actor and uh one of her
Sage pieces of advice and wisdom is is
if you get the opportunity always do a
Christmas thing because uh that will
bless you each year yeah for sure or uh
you know Hollywood we could finally do a
Hanukkah thing because apparently
everybody keeps telling me that
Hollywood's run by Jews but where the
[__] are the Hanukkah movies okay
I've done like one or two yeah animated
um what's what's the budget yeah that's
what I'm curious about what is the
budget on this domestic gross 50 mil I
made 76 million worldwide that's amazing
wow okay very very very very very good
job way to go team okay so they've they
made their money back and then some they
they at least tripled their budget
uh budget which which I mean that sounds
about right yeah
explosions and all of that you know what
they didn't spend on location they did
spend on theatrics well yeah all you
need is that one house and then the
woods basically and then you know there
are a couple other sets but yeah it
didn't seem like the most expensive
movie and two I mean at the outset you
imagine like you hear again producers of
John Wick you see Santa Claus in a
die-hard scenario I think I from the
outside might have assumed that this
would be like a much more just like
non-stop action like Runners on Runners
kind of movie and I like that it does
certainly have the action it has the
Carnage but it's not like only that and
it is like they do take time for the
story with little Trudy they take time
for the family stuff at least to some
degree and I thought they proportioned
everything pretty well overall I mean
it's it's uh it's pretty like spread out
between everybody like I guess Part of
Me Maybe expected a bit more of like the
way you spend so much of like Die Hard
with John McLean almost the whole time
uh whereas this you are cutting around
to a lot but I thought like the way they
thought it out you know was pretty
conscientious overall there are a little
couple little things where yeah you're
like did they just stop looking for her
or what but um yeah how did she get into
the attic but yeah I feel like I missed
something there but for the most part I
thought it was yeah it's like it wasn't
too high on like the oh we got our edgy
Santa kind of concept like I thought it
used that flavor but without being like
lurid and and like okay bro about it and
I like their weird colorful cast of
henches and stuff like that and John
Leguizamo like he's he's one of those
actors who seems like he can Traverse
just like any grade of Cinema like a
grade Z Grade B grade in between and
he's always great he always shows up you
know and I I appreciated uh his like
Christmas Vendetta like that's a hard
thing to sell because like it is a
little silly and being like man
Christmases were great until my dad lost
his job and then I was responsible for
this guy's death it ruined my entire
life in my house
I like the Bert character because it's
just so classic uh influencer it's like
yeah like I'm glad that don't kill me
man kill that that person okay Christmas
is real don't forget about sinner you
end up dead like just so obnoxious and
the worst and you kind of want the
little [__] to die but you're like okay
he's a child yeah when he first showed
up I was like okay here we go yeah yeah
his first line is like every stock thing
an influencer character is supposed to
say I liked it um but but as the movie
went along to like I appreciated that
they didn't even though this movie does
have characters who are a bit despicable
at least among the family members and
stuff like that especially uh the the
sister is like such a sycophant but I
liked that the movie some movies you
could tell really hate certain
characters and I didn't feel like this
movie was doing too much of that as far
as Christmas movies go what tier slash
like what other movies do you feel like
are equivalent to how much you like this
obviously this isn't a this isn't a
Miracle on 34th Street this isn't uh
um this isn't uh uh
um what's my favorite Christmas movie
the the It's a Wonderful Life this isn't
and this isn't Love Actually this is
maybe even as an elf for people but it's
also not like that bottom tier Christmas
movie that you can't get through where
does this kind of stand for you
that's a good question I mean I don't
know how I would like number rated
against those movies because it's doing
a different thing like this would be
like I'll I would pull this out like
early on in the Christmas season when I
want something that's yeah like fun and
irreverent but that doesn't have to be
sort of like the most thematic display
of Christmas but like I thought this is
oh I I personally would reach for this
much sooner than a bad Santa like a bad
santa I think is you just gotta you
gotta really want and like that kind of
like constantly dark and uh you know
raunchy Hume like there's it takes a lot
of effort for me to get to the redeeming
qualities of bad Santa
um did you like the night before did you
see the night before
um yes that's the one with Seth Rogen
and Joseph Gordon-Levitt and Michael
Shannon plays the stoner guy yeah yeah I
like that movie it must be like on tear
with there for you I probably like this
a little better than that but I did like
that movie and so yeah I would put it in
that yeah this isn't necessarily like
one of the god-tier like Christmas
Staples necessarily but this is one
that's like really fun that I would be
happily uh I would be happy to include
in my you know holidays a b-tier
Christmas movie for you kind of yeah
yeah like a like a good like a like a
solid like you know that's that's the
kind of movie I think this is trying to
be and I don't think that's a bad thing
I think it's pretty good at doing what
it is and it doesn't outstay it's
welcome or make anything too annoying
and you know it feels appropriately
Christmassy and it has I do appreciate I
think the thing I was taking most of
back by was that they did
earnestly commit to the Heart Like
that's actually what my bump it a little
bit about like to the B plus you know is
is that like I was getting misty-eyed
during those scenes between Santa and
Trudy because those are just such sweet
moments and she is a lovely young
actress and her chemistry back and forth
with him even over the walkie-talkie was
just like really you were crying yeah
because it created this bubble amidst
all the chaos and that's the thing is
especially as a kid and and I and I feel
like this can affect you even you know
just all throughout life is yeah like
without people holding your family
hostage and trying to steal a bunch of
money and people dying and blah blah
like there's just so much chaos going
around all the time that sometimes yeah
just that little bubble of like you know
peace and you know connection and Solace
from that is is a is a lovely little
thing and I like that they created that
here between those two characters and
kind of used the die hardness in a way
that isn't just doing a diet hard you
know like I thought that they kind of
used instead of him in like John
McLean's like talking back and forth
with the hostages and stuff or the
hostage takers and stuff a lot uh during
that movie whereas here it's like he's
just talking back and forth with her a
lot and then getting into fights so it
is like it also kind of surprised me and
it's uh disposition of things
um and it's um distribution I should say
of things because you know again you are
kind of cutting around and things are a
bit messy like Santa Claus is not like
he's only got so much magic he can only
do the chimney thing you know a few
times if you know the JuJu's pumped up
and so like you know the geography felt
well contained to where uh yeah I just
felt like conscientious in in that way
and I wasn't having too much like but
he's magic why is he you know why is he
able to do this or why is he taking so
long to get over here he doesn't know
how it works yeah what's your favorite
Christmas movie
um
maybe it's a wonderful I mean it's a
wonderful life is like the the Thematic
one but the one that feels like
Christmas
um
it's always like Charlie Brown Christmas
or something short like that or the
Grinch cartoon
um I feel like
you know an underrated movie that I
think is really great is Arthur
Christmas oh I don't remember Arthur
Christmas EG animated movie that uh the
the Wallace and Gromit people I believe
were behind I think it was an aardman
production or something like that
um but yeah that is like a delightful
lovely imaginative and Earnest uh
Christmas movie or elf like things like
that certainly elf my elf is definitely
a favorite
I think anything that combines that sort
of level of you know Whimsy and
Christmas love but also that has you
know some some Quirk and some fantasy
about it or something like that is
always a nice thing and so yeah like
something like this I I thought had like
that that nice element of like it's got
some magic not too much it's not relying
too heavily on gimmicks and things and
uh yeah yeah it's pretty solid cool
what's your favorite Christmas movie
wonderful life or Love Actually those
are my one and two oh my God it's so
good it's so good oh it's good I meet a
lot of girls who don't like that movie
funny enough really yeah well I wonder
what the correlation is
it's a good question I don't know we
should get them all in a room and have a
and have a debate focus group it yeah
yeah I know I I guess because some of
the perspectives and stuff like that
don't let uh I feel like the some of the
female characters in that movie kind of
get the harsh the harsh side of
Christmas certainly of the of the
Christmas love sickness you know what's
actually like maybe the least fun thing
in the world debating somebody who
doesn't like a movie that you like and
having to like explain why you like it
yeah because my maybe least favorite
quality in a person is if you like
something and they try to convince you
not to like it it's like why would you
want me not to like this thing I yeah
like I don't know I I I
I rarely these days feel compelled
anymore to argue some of the other
movies
unless someone like just comes out the
gate trying to be a jerk about it or
something like ah whatever you know I'm
not that concerned about changing your
mind necessarily what do you think about
the music
I like the music I mean I liked uh I
think you pointed out during uh one of
those scenes just like the the use of
less than obvious Christmas feel like
there are certain Christmas Time songs
and and maybe there were a couple needle
drops that weren't specifically holiday
music but I did like uh I don't think so
they were really mostly like mostly yeah
and I liked I appreciated that I was
just like oh cool you're reaching for
again you start off with like Holly
Jolly Christmas which is a classic but
uh either way having yeah kind of a nice
medley of uh you know she sings Jingle
Bells at one point but the actual music
used in the you know soundtrack is less
you know uh is more off the beaten path
stuff which I thought was neat and then
the rest of the score around it was
certainly fine I didn't like find myself
like oh man this Christmas scores really
like I was more pulled in by what was
happening on screen but I thought it
nicely supported everything that was
going on you ready for a quick test sure
name a Hanukkah Song
that isn't the dreidel song no that's
okay okay good okay yeah I mean dreidel
dreidelity yeah yeah let's go
and when you're drying ready oh dreidel
I will play Hey really good hey really
good it's having a gila Hanukkah Song
um no but sure uh you know Hanukkah
Hanukkah come light the menorah I know
I've heard that Adam Sandler oh yeah
yeah yeah
there we go and celebrate
cats don't smoke marijuana
yes that's right I don't think he
doesn't I don't think he's just don't
smoke marijuana I'm just doing it for
the kids yeah yeah cause this is
for kids there's a child in the this was
R-rated right definitely okay most
definitely there's too much swearing in
violence the violence and and yeah it's
like I thought the fights were not like
the most mind-blowing fights I've ever
seen but there was like that one shot
that they had a lot of long takes during
where he's fighting I think that first
Hench where he's like using the light
string and kind of learning how to
incorporate all the I don't know just
kind of finding his footing having to
fight these dudes and uh and yeah I
thought the way that they utilized
various decorations and and things it
seems like they they had like a laundry
list of like okay we gotta get the
nativity scene here we gotta get a
string of lights we gotta get some
tinsel we gotta get the tree we gotta
get a star we gotta get everything fake
snow and uh and yeah there's some some
cathartic fights and stuff like that
here and there fakes now yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah all in all pretty
solid I liked it I enjoyed it quite a
bit and it left me uh more heartwarmed
than I was expecting that's good yeah me
too which is what you which is what I
was afraid wouldn't happen I was afraid
that they would just be like aren't we
so cool because we got Santa just
beating fools down are you saying you
didn't believe
I did Believe by the end but at the
beginning I I mean I walked in with
enthusiasm just because everybody I know
is like this is so great and uh and yeah
and and my faith was rewarded I feel
like I'm a True Believer now and forever
we're in the power and magic of krimbus
oh that's dude next time it's a crimbus
it's just a mispronunciation of
Christmas but
you could do a sequel where he has to
either fight or team up with or somehow
interact with Krampus oh
because that's that's a whole you know
there's a whole historical lore I wanted
to see Mrs Claus and Rudolph I did too I
did too but I I liked even even that
I thought was nicely handled because
it's you know we've seen a hero with
latent action skills and estranged wife
before and and I like at least we got
that letter from her that was cute yeah
and it suggested like okay she's still
around and they still have their
relationship I guess that he just yeah
it's been so long that yeah it's hard to
keep it you know alive and he's already
depressed like Santa's already a
depressed guy in this movie drinks a lot
yeah and I thought the way he played
that too was Earnest again it wasn't
like ah this Santa is not your
grandpappy's Santa it's like no I I get
how he became this guy and I thought
David Harbor like hats off to him he
nailed it because yeah and and he's so
great at like throwing away lines and
and like you know doing that really
understated thing especially when he's
like been beaten to a pulp but uh but
yeah like you've got to really be able
to ride the line and I definitely bought
him as Viking Warrior guy and as you
know warm loving father Christmas or at
least Father Christmas who misses that
man magic and love that more people used
to you know engage over
so I'm with you yeah that's good from us
well are you guys with us let us know
your thoughts down in the comments did
you see this Christmas time and uh and
would you where would you rank it in
your holiday Pantheon of favorite
holiday movies
and uh yeah much love to you all be good
this year love that too that he's able
to keep track of the Henry yeah get on
the nice list naughty list that's a
great call
um but yeah much love and hey before we
get out of here let's do a patreon
take it away oh oh oh
pandemic Jones
I've got a belly full of jelly
that's Christmas yes it is may you have
the Marist of Christmases pandemic Jones
and for you and only you I will release
the pandemic and it's no longer you can
just be Jones again
it's a Christmas miracle yeah it really
is oh you're welcome dude now we gotta
come up with a festive new nickname for
him okay you can just be P Jones
yeah
get in there DJ he loves to be in his PJ
PJ yes there you go pajama Jones there
that's scary Christmas uh that's your
Christmas moniker so during the months
of December and the first half of
November or the second half of November
this year who wants to get out of your
PJs listen PJ the deal is we're right
now I hope you're in flannel I hope
you're in silk I hope you're in corduroy
cotton what are the PJ materials or hey
if you want to be in your if your PJs
are your birthday shoot suit you know
some people like to sleep like that
that's okay that's one pair of PJs you
never want to get out of yeah
I love you
get all happy
thank you